[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how App Engine can help
you ship your next great app
idea.
App Engine is a fully managed
serverless application platform
with simple administration.
Write your code in any of
the supported languages,
or run custom containers with
the language and framework
of your choice.
When your code is ready,
run gcloud app deploy.
App Engine handles the
work of uploading your code
and running it on Google Cloud.
It seamlessly scales from
zero to millions of requests
as your app becomes popular, and
you only pay for what you use.
You can easily host different
versions of your app and split
traffic between them for A/B
testing and incremental feature
rollouts.
You can debug and monitor
your app, even in production.
And for the security
of your app,
App Engine offers free
managed SSL certificates
on your custom domain.
App Engine works as a great
backend for mobile apps, APIs,
websites and more.
So next time you've
got a cool app
you want to ship quickly, take
a minute to look at App Engine.
To learn more, check out
cloud.goole.com/appengine.